5 bebé kamín ser más y xvii nang el
swing
ar inem
quedan en pichichi sois atitlán
estoy acá porque muchas personas han
creído en mí
quisiera compartirles porque creo que
hay personas que han creído en mí y como
estas personas han cambiado mi vida
y yo crecí con una personalidad
tímida y
tenía pocos amigos me daba pena hablar
con las personas incluso saludarlas
cuando fui adolescente no le pude decir
a la persona a la primera persona de
quien me enamoré que me gustaba
porque siempre buscaba la oportunidad de
salir corriendo
y en este proceso he aprendido bastante
que si se puede cambiar y se puede
romper con las limitaciones de la
realidad de las relaciones sociales
las primeras personas que creyeron en mí
fueron mis padres
ellos me ayudaron e incluso me acompañan
ahora que tengo una familia
mi papá me llevó al campo a trabajar la
tierra
pero al mismo tiempo me llevo a una
pequeña maquila a aprender observando
entonces aprendí
a confeccionar pantalones
logré desarrollar estas habilidades
también está
y mi mamá mi mamá me enseñó a hilar
entonces aprendí
a tejer en telar de cintura desde su
preparación hasta su entrega final hasta
su limpieza final
afortunadamente ellos me enviaron a la
escuela
estando en la escuela reprobé 2º
primaria porque me fue difícil aprender
a leer realmente me fue muy difícil este
trabajo
la maestra de 2º primaria me dijo tú no
puedes leer
vas a perder el grado y se lo dijo
también a mi mamá mi mamá se preocupó
ella nunca fue a la escuela por lo cual
no aprendió a leer ni escribir pero
cuando eso cuando fue joven aprendió a
leer porque leía su biblia
entonces en casa comenzó a darme
lecciones de deletreo de sílabas y de
pronunciamiento y me ayudó a desarrollar
esa habilidad de lectura que necesitaba
para avanzar en la escuela
cuando fui joven
es decir entre la juventud y la
adolescencia
llegué al instituto al diversificado
uno de los profesores que creyó en mí es
denis este profesor es como un
cazatalentos él identifica jóvenes que
tienen potencial y los apoya a salir
adelante él me encontró a mí a pesar de
mis limitaciones de relaciones sociales
me dio una pequeña beca para seguir
estudiando y me íntegro a sus
actividades sociales y me puso al frente
de mis compañeros
en aquel entonces
yo estudié para ser maestro
y aprendí
que es importante relacionarse con las
personas porque estaba trabajando con
niños con jóvenes y me tocaba
relacionarme con padres de familia e
incluso con autoridades
pero cuando estaba haciendo el trabajo
de docente encontré que los niños tienen
pocas limitaciones a acceso a libros
porque no los tienen en casa y las
escuelas tienen
contados libros en el aula incluso los
maestros no cuentan con muchos recursos
para trabajar con los niños
entonces comencé a compartir esta
necesidad y a preguntarles a los
maestros cómo veían esta necesidad de
ellos y también encontré que los malos
otros maestros sentían que faltan
recursos en las escuelas
entonces se comenzó a formar un pequeño
grupo de maestros y líderes comunitarios
en torno al proyecto de la biblioteca
comenzamos a integrar un grupo y
comenzamos a desarrollar este proyecto
de biblioteca en la biblioteca ya había
una pequeña biblia había ya una pequeña
pero de muy contados libros e incluso
libros de de años anteriores
pero ellos en estas reuniones que
teníamos me nombraron presidente del
comité de construcción de la biblioteca
en ese momento no entendía que era eso
porque era muy joven no entendía qué
implicaciones tenía ser presidente del
comité de construcción de una biblioteca
pero juntos con los docentes y los
líderes comunitarios
logramos hacer que la comunidad
colaborará en este proyecto entonces
colaboraron los niños los jóvenes los
padres de familia ellos trajeron arena y
piedra y mano de obra
y conseguimos que la municipalidad
hiciera también su aporte y encontramos
a la fundación ricky que apoya en el
proceso de construcción de bibliotecas
comunitarias en el país que también nos
ayudó en el proceso de construcción de
esta biblioteca
cuando finalizamos el proceso de
construcción de la biblioteca
los libros que teníamos de la anterior
se quedaron en una pequeña esquina y
había un vacío muy grande
entonces mi amigo pablo de fundación
ricky me dijo ahora te necesitamos para
que dirijas esta biblioteca un reto muy
grande porque
y los libros con que contábamos era muy
reducido
pero también teníamos que repensar cómo
hacer el proceso de la biblioteca porque
la biblioteca en este país es muy
es muy pasiva incluso se les dice a los
niños que no hablen y que hagan silencio
pero esta biblioteca se fue convirtiendo
en un lugar de descubrimiento
y se fue desarrollando un proceso de
programación en ella en lectura en
fortalecimiento de la cultura en
fortalecimiento de actividades juveniles
y desarrollo de una programación muy
fuerte la llevamos a un modelo de
biblioteca nacional recibió un
reconocimiento hace dos años como
biblioteca como la mejor biblioteca
innovadora en guatemala pero también la
hemos llevado a hacer la biblioteca
miembro de la de las bibliotecas
innovadoras del mundo en una red global
que se llama be on access
este reconocimiento me llevó a ser
presentado al mundo por facebook la red
social más grande como presentándome al
mundo como el bibliotecario
en su décimo aniversario
actualmente esta biblioteca tiene otro
nivel y ha crecido
y es un modelo de biblioteca que se ha
generado para el país pero también para
la población de san juan la laguna
en el año 2014 yo me quedé sin empleo
y buscando oportunidades
hablé con organizaciones pidiendo
trabajo pero no lo logré
y afortunadamente me encontré con mi
amiga john joan está aquí con nosotros
hoy ella es una de las personas que
creyó en mí
en ese momento
estaba conociendo una herramienta que se
llama rachel y ella me preguntó qué
puedes hacer con rachel qué puedes hacer
con ella
y yo pensé y le dije esta herramienta la
podemos llevar a todo el país la podemos
poner en cada una de las escuelas porque
hay mucha necesidad de información y
contenido para maestros y para los niños
me gustaría explicarles qué es rachel
rachel es una biblioteca digital que
tiene los mejores contenidos educativos
del internet debidamente empaquetados y
organizados para que puedan ser usados
en lugares donde no hay internet
funcionan desde este pequeño dispositivo
que se llama raspberry país que tiene el
tamaño de un teléfono que una vez
conectado a energía eléctrica emite una
señal inalámbrica y los teléfonos las
tablet y las laptops se pueden conectar
a ella incluso se puede configurar en
una red con camps con con cables para
computadoras de mesa
el primer año de este trabajo
joan me ayudó a llegar a estos a llegar
a muchas escuelas cercanas aquí en la
antigua pero también en lugares lejanos
con poco acceso cómo llegar al triángulo
ixil
y también usamos transporte colectivo es
fascinante viajar en camioneta en tuc
tuc en pico sobre los microbuses y andar
en las comunidades para poder llevar
este recurso
los primeros pasos que hicimos para
llevar esta herramienta
es identificar directores para
comunicarnos con ellos y hacerles
demostraciones de este recurso
lo hacía casi todo al principio
instalaba esta biblioteca si era
necesario con ayuda de los docentes les
enseñaba cómo conectar cables para que
podamos hacer una red en la escuela
entrenaba a los maestros para usar esta
herramienta pero que él pero para que la
usaran para desarrollar aprendizaje
y encontramos algo que los maestros se
les ilumina el rostro cuando encuentran
que pueden contar corre con recursos
digitales con libros con música con
información para su escuela para el
grado al que están dando clases de
manera gratuita en sus teléfonos
esto nos llevó a crear
la asociación mundo posible que es una
organización que surgió de cero y la
hemos estado haciendo visible
actualmente con la colaboración de
muchos amigos e instituciones hemos
llevado esta herramienta a más de 208
escuelas en todo el país ahora
y muchos maestros están usando este
recurso y están teniendo acceso gratis a
este contenido
por eso
yo estoy muy agradecido con las personas
que han creído en mí para llegar
a estar en este momento en la posición
de director nacional de esta
organización y llevar este recurso a las
escuelas
porque yo yo pienso que las personas que
creen en uno le cambian la vida porque
le permiten y le dan una oportunidad
me gustaría finalizar contándoles dos
frases con los cuales mi hijo miguel me
ha sorprendido
en una ocasión uno de sus juguetes había
sido puesto en la parte alta de un
mueble
y él se esforzaba por alcanzar ese
juguete y no lo lograba por más que se
estiraba y no lo lograba
fue conmigo y me dijo baja mi lancha
entonces fui al mueble y tiroteo también
comencé a simular que no alcanzaba el
juguete y me toma del pantalón y me dice
tú puedes
el otro día estaba en la cocina y estaba
haciendo los panqueques
rápidamente llegó conmigo y me dice
déjame intentarlo
por favor
cuando tú escuchas que una persona te
dice tú puedes
abre tu mente y tu corazón y también de
déjame intentarlo
porque tú también puedes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]